well it was actually it was really busy
you know especially for the first few
days there was lots going on us
constantly doing my observations i was
having fluids and lots of blood tests
things like that so so it's really busy
actually and and i didn't have a lot of
time to really ponder the full sort of
the potential for the illness
yeah yeah it's a little bit strange it's
like I suppose it's like being in a in a
fish tank in a way but because it's all
it's all clear it's all clear plastic
around you so it wasn't I wouldn't say
it was claustrophobic it's you know it's
strange you know everything goes on in
that in that tiny little tiny little
space so you know there's not much
privacy or anything like that but all in
all yeah you've got other things on your
mind than the than the confines of the
tent really okay
what's up it's devastating
yeah we'll obviously I was very lucky in
several ways firstly in the in the
standard of care that I received which
is a world apart from what people are
receiving in West Africa at the moment
despite you know a lot of organizations
best efforts so I had amazing care which
is one difference the other difference
to a lot of Ebola cases that my symptoms
never progressed to the worst stages of
the disease people that I've seen dying
horrible deaths really I never I I had
some unpleasant symptoms but nothing
nothing compared to some of you know the
worst of the disease especially when
people end up dying and I didn't I I
never had any vomiting for example which
was nice but a lot of a lot of people
especially those dit and go on to die
get vomiting